in the preview right on time uh me we
will just be doing a quick introductions
on the chart here before we start like
we always do so I'm rashak Khan I'm your
host of
today weinar I'm joining all the way
from Bangalore India and we would love
to know where tuning in from so you can
drop us hello on the chart let us know
your name and also where I tuning in
from and please do mention your name
because sometimes it's pretty hard to
make out your name from your email IDs
so that's all and also I think we have
good 5 minutes before we start and I
seen folks have already started joining
in so uh you can give your introductions
on the chat here and uh we'll just get
to know each other a little better
before we start so it's always good to
network right these events before we
start awesome I think we have our first
introduction here I can see uh Terry has
joined from Indiana so U welcome Terry
and uh folks who basically are still uh
basically joining uh so we are just
getting started Ed and we'll be starting
right on time in few minutes meanwhile I
see one introduction in the Q&A box as
well so uh uh okay Alis if I'm
pronouncing your name right please
correct me uh has joined us from Miami
USA so that's great and uh for other
folks uh we just will be starting in a
few minutes just on time Meanwhile we're
just doing quick Round Up introductions
on the chat here so you can let us know
your name and where are you join us from
on the chat and a quick tip before we
start uh so in case you have any
questions for our speaker who already
joined us Jeremy uh you can let us know
in the Q&A box we'll be taking questions
from there I'll take you through the few
ground rules we have for the session uh
in few minutes meanwhile we'll just do a
quick round of introductions on the chat
here so I see uh introductions have
already started coming in the chat here
and as we are also live on our YouTube
channel as well so so uh folks who have
joined us on YouTube live are watching
us you can give your introductions there
on the chat as well I'll check that
out okay uh also uh folks folks who have
uh basically joined on our YouTube
channel uh where the program is also
live uh we will also be taking questions
from the chat box from there as well so
you can let us know if you have any
questions uh you can let us know on the
YouTube chat live box there and we will
take questions from there as well only
thing is just make sure that questions
are related to data science and the
program so that's
all I can see a few more introductions
coming in on chat so I can see Matthew
has joined from uh Texas us USA I can
see Ahmed has joined from Chicago and
azizul has joined us from Canada and he
says that he's a project manager so
welcome everyone we'll be starting uh in
few minutes we just uh have few minutes
left good time two minutes time to
basically start and do a quick round of
introductions there and uh folks who are
watching us on YouTube right now and can
also uh share your instructions on the
YouTube live chat box
awesome uh I think uh we are getting a
lot of introductions on the chat here so
that's great uh so for folks who have
just joined us right now uh we are just
doing quick introductions and we
starting the program toie uh right on
time in few
minutes
I can see uh saleim has joined from
Seattle and adola has joined from Lagos
Nigeria my data science master's degree
is in vo so that's great ad
Mula and uh folks who are just joining
right now we are just starting the
session and uh we're just doing a quick
round of introductions on the chat here
before we start so uh folks who have
just joined right now just to let you
know that I'm rashak Khan I'm your host
for today's webinar and I'm still to be
your host today uh we just doing a Qui R
of introductions on the chat here uh you
can let us know your name and where are
you tuning in from and also for the
folks who are watching us live on
YouTube so before we start let me
quickly take you through few ground
rules we have for the session uh so in
case you have any questions for our
speaker Jeremy who has already joined us
you can let us know in the Q&A box uh
Q&A box is something you can navigate
very easily just beside the chat box if
you're join from your mobile laptop
desktop and uh the session is being
recorded in case you want to go through
the recording of the session once again
in in case you have missed anything you
can basically uh expect a follow-up
email with the recording link and the
webinar certificate and also the bonus
offer for attendance webinar now what
exactly is the bonus offer bonus offer
is for the program Caltech data science
boot cab which we'll be talking about uh
in basically sometime about that and
also to request a proof of attendance
for this webinar you can enter your full
name in the post webinar survey
basically the full name will reflect in
the certificate of this webinar so uh
this happens when basically we end the
session uh that is of 160 minutes
duration and you will get a zoom popup
which shows you a survey and that is
where you can put down your full name
there that will be really helpful for us
to basically put down your name and your
certificate and also uh to get the
certificate of this webinar you need to
stay till the end of the session so that
is how you can basically attain the
certificate as well I can see Sora has
joined from Mumbai India and says I'm
completing my last year of B degree
specializing inl so that's interesting
Sora uh thank you for joining we're just
doing quo introductions and also taking
you through the ground rules here uh
this program is powered by simply uh
World on number one online boot camp uh
we are very proud with that we have been
in the digital space uh for the last
over 13 years and we have been
transforming lives by empowering people
V skills like AIML data science business
Antics cloud computing uh full stock
development product management and many
more uh categories which we cover also
we have advanced over 5 lakh plus
careers in over 150 plus countries and
we have plenty of qualified trainers uh
basically who uh take up these programs
also uh to move on uh let's talk about
the agenda of today's session so we will
be talking uh about you getting to to
know you a little better how we can help
you out in your career and we'll be
talking about data science careers in
2024 and also we'll be talking about how
the calch ctme uh program prepares you
and also how this program gets your job
ready uh we'll be taking the enrollment
steps of the program and also there will
be a special duration for the Q&A part
so now in case you have putting
questions in the Q&A box I will try to
take as many questions as possible
throughout the session which usually
Jeremy does uh but in in case we are not
able to answer your question immediately
please don't worry just have a little
patience we'll take it towards the end
so thank you so much once again uh for
everyone who has just joined right now
we we just quickly going through the
ground rules and agenda of today's
session and uh as we move on we'll start
with a quick poll just to get to know
you a little better uh so we can see a
quick PLL on your screen
here
hi so sorry I faced a little glitch uh
so yeah I was talking about that we'll
be getting to know you a little better
and we'll start with getting to know you
know uh how many years of experience do
you currently have so you can see a
quick poll on your screen here uh where
you can see four quick options you can
choose from so now when I talk about
experience I'm talking about work
experience here so uh the four options
I'll just redot those for you so the
first one is less than 2 years second
one 2 to 5 years third one 5 to 10 years
and the last one more than 10 years so
you can choose the most suitable option
for you uh for folks replying on chat
they can also let us know on the poll as
well that will give us an understanding
as well for usually folks uh join us
from different different set of
experiences and that's pretty
interesting right uh to be a part of
such crowd as well uh who have joined
you so uh through this poll you can let
us know how many years of experience do
you currently
have and uh in case this does not cover
your response uh you can let us know in
the Q&A box as
well okay I can see
uh okay I I think there's an
introduction on the Q&A box so uh thank
you so much for the introduction I think
I saw that introduction on the chat as
well and I can see Alex says that he has
two to five years of experience so
that's great and I see more
introductions coming in on
chat I think I'll just give uh 5 Seconds
more for the poll here because I see
most of the folks have already shared
responses for the poll so once once
again I'll just read out for you how
many years of experience do you
currently have is what the current poll
which says and you can choose from the
uh from the options which you can see on
your screen uh whatever is the most
suitable option for you in terms of your
work experience so last 5 seconds for
few folks who are still basically voting
so five 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end the
poll and also share the results with
your
folks so as you can see that uh 32% of
the folks who have joined us have more
than 10 years of experience and uh
equally 32% of the folks who have joined
us have less than two years of
experience so that's great and uh 19% of
the folks who have joined us have 2 to 5
years of experience and 16% of the folks
have 5 to 10 years of experience so uh
thank you so much for sharing that with
us and it's always good to see folks
joining from different different set of
experiences as we move on uh I would
love to introduce our speaker today uh
Jeremy samon uh Jeremy uh first of all
would like to thank you for taking the
time off for this program preview today
we have something very interesting lined
up for them we'll be talking about how
they can unleash their data science
career in 2024 through this calic data
science boot camp uh so we would love to
know a little bit about you uh can you
share a
introduction yeah absolutely uh yeah
great to be here um glad to see
everybody in the chat looks like we have
a pretty diverse crowd very cool um yeah
so a little bit about me um see I listed
as the chief data scientist for R Data
Solutions that actually is my my firm my
consultancy um so I actually have a
handful of clients uh biggest one right
now is I'm primarily spending my time as
the uh kind of principal data scientist
for uh what's called the digital
identity engineering team at
Equifax um so you know they're probably
everybody's heard of Equifax right
they're a big one of the big three
credit bureaus um but actually they do
perform a number of services for you
know many clients in the clients in the
financial services sector uh so
primarily for Lending institutions uh we
actually provide services around uh
detecting and preventing various types
of fraud uh in particular my team is
interested in identity fraud so uh we
basically are applying machine learning
and AI to the detecting of identity
fraud as it's occurring in what are
called new account openings so as people
apply for you know depository accounts
new lines of credit things like that
we're basically taking a close look or
our models rather are taking a close
look at those applications to determine
if we think any type of fraud is taking
place on those those accounts um but
overall I've actually been in industry
for a little over 15 years uh was 15
years back in July this last
summer and I've actually been in a
number of sectors in my time uh that
I've been here so uh spent about three
years doing consulting in healthcare
trying to help hospitals to be more
profitable um you know that's
profitability is actually a huge problem
for hospitals in the United States um
then moved into the financial services
sector and did a lot of different things
so uh like indirect procurement spending
analysis a lot of modeling around that
around like vendor risk uh you know uh
consolidations that kind of thing uh did
some work in real estate as well kind of
on the investing side uh for you know
commercial real estate firms uh which if
you guys have been following the news
that would be an interesting space to be
in today for
sure although that was still an
interesting space to be in you know 10
years ago it was a lot of fun um did
some algorithmic trading also on the
hedge fund side uh started out kind of
getting into fraud detection actually
uh with MasterCard uh detecting payment
fraud um had a little bit of a detour
into research uh with a startup based
out of Silicon Valley uh looking into
ways to accelerate deep learning
inference on a novel chip architecture
that had been developed uh by that
company uh and then from there went into
Supply Chain management optimizing
Supply chains and things like that for
about three years and um back in the
back in the financial services fraud
detection space at Equifax so I've seen
seen a number of different
things uh thank you so much Jeremy for
your introduction that's a lot of
experience I must say and uh so as we
are Live on YouTube as well uh someone
just asked me that are we just streaming
it live is just a video no we are
actually doing a live Zoom session
pramsh so hi so left a comment so just
to let you know uh so uh so as we move
on uh we'll be starting with uh talking
about careers in data science in 2024 so
uh let's talk about how the data is
driving uh 2024's economy J
me all right you're asking me how how do
I think data science is going to be
driving economics yeah 2024 yeah oh yeah
so okay um yeah excellent question I
think that uh data science and AI this
past year have already been you know
pretty big drivers of of growth and
investment uh in kind of the business
sectors various business sectors of the
United States uh but I think that was
really just kind of the beginning I
think that there were a lot of uh you
know companies that were you know a
foothold this past year that we're going
to see a lot of great things from and I
think that Ai and machine learning are
actually going to transform a lot of a
lot of spaces a lot of Industry sectors
uh in the United States which is I think
both a good thing and a bad thing it
kind of just depends on on your
Viewpoint uh um you know I say to my
kids um you know back in the 90s when I
grew up a little bit dating myself uh
you know if somebody didn't really you
know study hard in school or didn't get
very good grades or they dropped out
then people would kind of there was
almost the saying of like oh well you
know pizzas don't deliver themselves and
I keep telling my kids like well
actually they do now so you have to be
so just stay in school uh so you know I
think there are a lot of jobs that we're
going to see uh being automated I think
that's the a lot of people are afraid of
that and I think that that is a real
thing to be concerned about that we're
probably going to start seeing a lot of
that uh I think in other spaces though
where people have been concerned about
you know job automation through AI I
think it's more going to be that human
creativity and productivity is going to
be just mostly augmented by artificial
intelligence and I think that that's
probably going to happen across the
board like it's it would be faster to
tell you what industries that won't
happen in uh because I think it's going
to be happening you know basically
everywhere all over the world so uh yeah
I think it's going to be a massive space
to be in for
sure uh thank you so much for sharing
that with us and also as you can see the
numbers here so uh the fortune business
Insight says that uh the Big Data
spending will search from $41 41 billion
in 2019 uh to $116 billion in by 2027 so
uh that is basically the growth of data
in 2024 and Beyond as well so uh as we
have talked about the data uh in the
upcoming year we let's talk about the
hottest skills in the data science space
in 2024 as well as you can see jery
there are so many skills you know which
will be in demand in 2024 but maybe uh
you can uh tell us uh something which uh
folks who come from a completely
different background and have no
knowledge of data science what skill
they can take up you know to start with
yeah absolutely so kind of the first
things that you would want to you know
start looking into
uh would be sort of the classical
machine learning so I like that that
bullet point is actually first on this
slide uh because that is a great way to
to get started um and that incorporates
actually a number of things that are on
here so like basy and statistics uh
absolutely is sort of the basis of
machine learning so that would be a good
thing to know uh with a view toward
learning about machine learning models
and how you uh how you apply that to
solving various business problems um
there's also Al very much the um kind of
the mathematical mindset that I think is
required for that as well that is is
needed uh you know because you'll talk
to a lot of business stakeholders as a
data scientist and they have a lot of
you know excellent experience they have
a lot of excellent intuition a lot of
excellent domain knowledge in their
space and so they can often identify you
know what kinds of things uh do they
think should be pursued what kinds of
things should they go after or should we
go after in the business business uh as
the data scientist you have to kind of
listen to them uh you know listen to
their their intuitions and their
insights that they have sort of treat a
lot of that like it's a hypothesis and
value basically validate all of that in
the data and ultimately give everything
sort of more of this like formal
mathematical structure right so rather
than this you know kind of maybe
nebulous idea of like well we should try
to be better about this or we should try
to be better about you know this this
process or that process you actually
really do need to uh you know kind of
give everything this more formalized
structure like okay what exactly are we
trying to achieve what are the inputs
what are the outputs how are we going to
measure this all that kind of stuff um
and really having to learn how a lot of
these machine learning models work what
do the inputs and outputs look like how
do you score them all that kind of stuff
kind of forces you to kind of view the
business World in that way uh so I think
that is probably the most
Central most critical skill to all of
this um and then all this other stuff I
think kind of gets kind of added in so
like time series analysis is just you
know kind of a particular application of
different machine learning same with
computer vision and natural language
processing it's just a particular kind
of like application domain that you'll
see uh a lot of these things to sort of
if you're working as a data scientist
you kind of start to
um see these Technologies without
thinking about it too much so like cloud
computing so like AWS azure gcp
absolutely uh you're going to be using
those Technologies as you're you know
dealing with large data sets as you are
uh you know training your models
deploying your models at this point I
think uh it's very rare that you're not
on some kind of cloud
platform so yeah a lot of these things
like Hadoop spark cloud computing all
that kind of stuff absolutely you're
going to have to know that sort of thing
um you know and just uh yeah it's it's
almost going to become this thing that
you like don't see or don't realize
you're doing or dealing as part of your
day-to-day job but absolutely is
critical um and also I think this bullet
Point's exciting the explainable AI
bullet point is huge because that is a
very active area of research in uh
machine learning and in AI so
particularly in you know the realm of
deep learning and artificial neural
networks um we have a very hard time
kind of interpreting some of these
models right and or you know any of them
really in certain uh
you know certain Arenas or certain
domains so you know it can be very very
difficult if you have to give any kind
of explanation of like why is my model
doing what it's doing why is it making
the decisions it's making and we've had
a lot of I think really big
breakthroughs in this area and there's
still a lot of active research happening
uh in that space and that's the thing
that we actually have to use quite a bit
uh at Equifax so you know our models are
actually used in credit decisions and so
you know if anyone who's is applying for
credit is denied you know their
applications denied for any reason uh
you know it's having your model be able
to you know being able to explain your
model or explain like why the decision
was made that was made uh isn't really a
nice to have it's actually like a
regulatory requirement so absolutely
we're uh doing a lot of exploration and
a lot of work in in this space as well
so uh Jeremy thank you so much for
taking us these uh training skills which
will be there in the DAT space it when
for uh folks U apologies for the spam
here we have removed the spammer here uh
I think this AI chatboard spam is like
again like ironic example of data
science you know so uh ignore that
please and also uh as we have talked
about so many skills which will be in
demand in 2024 I'm pretty sure you folks
have joined and you are aspiring to
become a data scientist uh in the future
so we would love to know like which of
these skills uh you would want to take
up in 2024 or you are planning to take
up or or you are already actually uh
studying those or basically learning
about those you can let us know on the
chart here so we would love to know that
you can look look at these skills here
and also Folks at YouTube as well who
have joined us you can let us know there
as well so uh folks we are uh actually
paying attention to to the YouTube live
chart as well so uh we will be taking
questions from there as well so please
do let us know if you have any questions
we'll take those questions in some time
so now that we have talked about the
skills here let's talk about the
trending data science career paths in
2024 so uh as you can see there are so
many career paths they can take up in4
uh so maybe Jeremy can take us through a
few of these career paths which will be
really good for folks who come from a
data science or a non data science
background yeah absolutely so um yeah I
think the one kind of job title that is
sort of the most catchall with all of
these that sort of gives you I guess
sort of the most options would just be
data
scientist uh kind of the trouble with it
I think is that uh what exactly does it
mean to be a data scientist um right
like what exactly does that job title
you know mean or what does it look like
day-to-day to be honest that actually
changes a bit um company to company uh
so there kind of different companies
will expect different things out of you
um you know just kind of based on what
they think a data scientist is or what
that means um
but generally you know you're the one as
the data scientist who is looking at the
data uh generating insights right kind
of helping people make sense of you know
these large amounts of data and uh
ultimately that often leads to building
and deploying models um which could be
machine learning models but it could be
all kinds of stuff right I mean there
are models that I've used that are kind
of more in the realm of like operations
research uh simulation you know
different things like that so yeah I
think data scientist the the job title
is quite Broad in terms of what it could
mean
uh some of these as well are almost sort
of kind of like getting rolled up into
Data scientists so like statistici
you'll still see that job title being
posted on job boards from time to time
um but uh you know it's like more and
more statisticians people who have
historically worked as statisticians are
just calling themselves data scientists
I would say that's also true about
Actuarial scientists and you know
quantitative analysts quantitative
researchers you know also known as
quants they're sort of like the data
scientists of the finance World um so
yeah a lot of those actually are kind of
starting to like roll up together um but
then yeah you have like AI research
scientists so that actually is I think a
very exciting career path to go into so
as a data scientist you'll use Ai and
machine learning a lot but mostly your
Innovation is going to be kind of in how
do you apply existing algorithms to new
business prod problems that you're
encountering um the development though
of the algorithms themselves is actually
done by AI research scientists so the
you know as you see new you know machine
learning and AI Tech techniques being
developed new papers being published
that kind of stuff that's sort of coming
out of that that space was the the AI
research
scientist um a relatively new one that's
kind of coming up I think more often now
is the machine learning engineer that's
being listed just under data scientist
so again this really comes down to like
what does your particular company think
a data scientist is or what they do
there are companies I've worked at or
worked with where you're not considered
a data scientist if you're not able to
deploy your own models right so it's
just kind of expected that a data
scientist is going to develop a model
and then also put that model into
production uh some companies though have
I think very you know big very complex
production environments that are tough
to navigate so it's almost kind of like
this whole other skill set in and of
itself right to be able to you know to
deal with that and to be able to scale
algorithms up and deploy them in a you
know in a completely sound productionize
way so the machine learning engineer
sort of emerged uh kind of as this go
between between like the data scientist
and the data engineer so they're they
kind of know enough about the ETL
pipeline you know maybe they're not a
full-blown data engineer but they know
enough about the pipeline that you know
datas flow through that data sets flow
through and they know enough about
machine learning that if you hand them a
model and say deploy this then they can
get that deployed uh efficiently and get
that plugged into the ETL pipeline into
the you know to all the different
processes that uh feed and consume that
model so uh that's I think a pretty hot
kind of upand cominging thing that
you'll
see uh data engineer I think is also
always solid uh it's actually a separate
career from data scientist so like I'm
not a data engineer at all uh but I do
rely very heavily on data Engineers
basically in any space where I'm working
because they're the ones that really
kind of get you connected to the data
they get it uh you know they they think
about all these things like oh well we
have these two
databases um that are updated at these
different rates and they communicate in
these ways and so how do we make sure
that like everything's totally
consistent and that you can trust the
data that you're getting out of both of
them and all that stuff so I wouldn't be
able to do what I do at all without data
Engineers so uh you know very glad to
have them around uh one thing to
consider as well in kind of choosing a
career path
uh is that you actually typically need
to have more data engineers in a company
than you need to have data scientists so
often you can get away with just having
one or two data scientists but you'll
often need three four or five data
Engineers for every data scientist that
you have so um just because of the
nature of the work that they're doing
you just often need more of them um and
they still you know uh you know it's not
really like a quality versus quantity
tradeoff they still make very good money
and they're just there more jobs kind of
out there for the data
Engineers um yeah everything else uh so
data analysts bi analysts they um
they're kind of more about just again
sort of visualizing the data making
reports they don't necessarily get so
much into the modeling and all that kind
of stuff um and then yeah we'll call out
the data architect as well so the data
architect is really essential uh in kind
of coming up with like what does the
whole solution look like right what does
your whole data structure look like um
you know is this a data lake is it a
data warehouse is it a you know data
fabric like they're the ones that have
to understand the difference between all
of these architectures uh what are the
company's needs what's appropriate like
you know what's really going going to be
like the best architecture uh to
implement all that kind of stuff so
those are also very very essential uh
professionals that are needed on any
team um but they're a little bit more
like the data scientists in that you
generally need like one or two of them
and then you're set so so something to
think
about uh thank you so much Jeremy for
taking us to a detailed explanation of
these titles uh someone in the Q&A box
also says thank you for the Insight on
different titles within Zeta science uh
as we are Live on YouTube as well we are
getting questions on the chat box there
something very related to the slide here
so I'll just read out that question for
you uh this is from uh banka
peral which is the very simple question
that which is good data science was full
stuck is this oh this is in the chat
let's see yeah um let's see can you say
it again U which which is good data
science or full
stack uh
so I would say here's kind of the the
interesting sort of caveat about that
so if you say that you're a full a full
stack data scientist that would kind of
imply that you uh can kind kind of do
the whole thing end to end right that
you can do the data engineering piece
that you're exceptionally good at the
you know statistical analysis and
machine learning piece and that you also
can then go ahead and deploy your own
models maintain those deployments you
know maintain the you know inference and
testing pipelines the monitoring all
that kind of
stuff um there kind of was this idea in
the industry for a while I'd say about
five years back that like the people
were looking for these like unicorns
that could do all of that but I think
after probably a year year and a half or
so they all kind of realized that uh for
the most part these unicorns don't exist
and that if they do exist if you find
one occasionally they want like double
the salary that anybody else is asking
for um and I think also on the other
side of that you know the you know what
few unicorns there were I think also
kind of realized that it wasn't super
worth it to be a unicorn because you it
was you know really a lot of work uh you
know took a lot of work and a lot a lot
of experience experience to have and to
maintain all these different skill
sets uh so it's almost like you're doing
the work of like two or three different
people but you're not really getting two
or three times the salary for being that
unicorn and so that's why we see that
there are kind of all these different
you know more specialized job titles
that have emerged because it's actually
just more beneficial for everybody on
both sides um to just go ahead and
specialize into hire Specialists and
things like that rather than trying to
be kind of like worried about being that
full stack you know data science unicorn
so
uh thank you so much JY for answering
that I hope Bank of per answers your
question uh please do let us know on the
YouTube live chat box and also uh as you
can see there are so many training data
science career paths you can take up in
2024 and Beyond which of these career
parts are you aspiring for or planning
to take up so you can let us know on the
chart here I'll just give one minute for
you to have a look and let us know on
the chart which of these uh data science
career paths you are aspiring for you
would want to
become
also I see uh we are getting a lot of
questions here in the Q&A box as well we
will uh be addressing your queries uh
throughout the session as we get time
but we'll be having your special
duration for the Q&A part as well so
please don't worry in case we are not
able to answer your question immediately
so uh you can let us know on the chat
like which of the r science careers you
are aspiring for uh now that we have
talked about skills we have talked about
careers uh we have talked about uh
basically what exactly is changing in
the data science uh economy here and uh
let's talk about what exactly is
changing in the data science space for
2024 as well so uh as you can see uh on
the screen here so jery can you take us
through what exactly is changing in data
science yeah so uh yeah this field is I
think changing rapidly in a number of
ways um one is the widespread adoption
right and integration of artificial
intelligence which is mentioned here on
the slide I think that's spoton um but
also the Technologies are moving really
quickly so like you have to really kind
of keep up with a lot of things that are
happening right so um you had chat GPT
uh get sort of released to the public
back in I think it was November of
2022 and uh that very rapidly changed
everything so that app um right or
product or whatever reached 100 million
users faster than anything else in
history uh and and by a lot it wasn't
even close
so you know you saw immediately this
widespread
adoption completely changed a lot of
attitudes and a lot of Minds about
artificial intelligence which I think is
good I think we're a little bit in a
hype cycle right now and there are a lot
of people that are just kind of asking
for it without knowing like why they
would need it or what it could possibly
be used for which is a thing that's hard
to deal with as a data scientist
especially in Consulting so you have to
kind of uh help sort of temper their
expectations and help them understand
you know be a little bit more organized
about what they want on to what they're
asking for but yeah that's absolutely
all over the place now you know tons of
clients are asking for it uh especially
in the large language model type type
space um yeah a lot of issues are being
raised I think about ethical data
practices I also saw a question in the
chat about kind of the uh bias
mitigation and explain or and ethical AI
so yeah there are a lot of uh kind of
real ramifications of using a and
machine learning because it's you know
it's a statistical approach it's never
perfect uh the models do make uh
mistakes they do make errors and so
there are you know real consequences to
that so it's like um you know and that
there are kind of observed biases that
emerge in certain domains where Ai and
machine learning are trying to be
applied uh particularly in criminal
justice there actually it has been some
use of machine learning models in
um sentencing and making parole
decisions uh you know things like that
and that there have been some you know
very uh real observed biases and how uh
inmates of different demographics or
defendants of different demographics are
treated even by Machine learning models
that are you know supposed to be uh fair
and unbiased that's why we started
trying to use them but it turns out
that's like not exactly happening so
yeah there is some real work that I
think needs to be done there to make
sure uh you know that these models are
still as accurate as possible but that
they're not inherently or intrinsically
unfair uh or you know biased toward any
any particular group um Quantum
Computing impact I'm not sure that we're
really seeing a whole lot of quantum
Computing impact in AI machine learning
yet uh again that might be one of those
things that just changes overnight all
the sudden uh but I think we still need
to see quite a bit more progress in the
quantum Computing space uh before that
really starts to have a real impact
especially in Industry uh on machine
learning uh yeah Automation and
automl that actually is a really big
thing um so there are more and more
tools now especially with the Advent of
large language
models that um you know allow like sort
of low code or no code uh kind of
implementation of solutions uh in fact
had a client
company I was talking to their VP of
data science
recently and they mentioned they had
kind of put this survey out to the whole
company and they had said you know what
do you guys think like what are some use
cases that you guys think we could apply
you know machine learning and AI to uh
they got an overwhelmingly you know huge
response right so they had thousands of
use cases submitted they then had to
review them to figure out like okay
which of these are actually plausible
which of these you know seem like we
really should Implement
them uh even after whittling it down
they still arrived at something like 450
use cases right and so another VP of
data science is looking at this saying
like well I've just got like my little
team like there's no way that we can uh
you know Implement 450 use cases for AI
or machine learning across this whole
Enterprise so they really are looking at
you know some of these tools like flow
wise or Lang flow like some of these uh
you know applications that let you do
sort of more like drag and drop or you
know low code no code types of options
for implementing large language model
Solutions and their hope is that if they
you know they're kind of like most of
these 450 use cases that we need to
implement are actually pretty simple and
straightforward to do and so we're
thinking we can basically kind of give
this autom ml tool to most of the people
who have come up with the idea for the
use cases and let them sort of self-
serve right let them sort of uh kind of
build their own solution and then we as
the data science team would only have to
really get involved with the things that
are more nuanced more complicated right
and that would require ire us to you
know that that don't aren't really
served by a low code no code option that
we would really have to kind of like you
know get in get down to the nuts and
bolts to implement um excuse me and then
yeah interdisciplinary skills absolutely
um you know as a data scientist and
machine learning exper machine learning
engineer you're typically um you know a
a mathematician or a computer scientist
right you're someone who kind of has
this experience with data and modeling
and things like that uh but there are
you know things that you don't
necessarily know about say real estate
or payment fraud or Healthcare or
whatever right and so in order to really
learn about a lot of the ins and outs of
those spaces so you can learn about what
sorts of data sources should you be
interested in how should you treat those
data sources um you know things like
that you really need to kind of rely on
the domain subject matter experts to
sort of you know kind of help you sort
of help direct your efforts as
well uh thank you so much jery for
taking us through what's changing in the
data science space for 2024 uh we do
have one question on our YouTube live
chat box uh that by PR Patel uh will the
numbers of employee in the company will
decrease after the arrival of AI
technology so that's an excellent
question uh I don't think anybody really
knows the answer to that unfortunately
I'd like to give you a more satisfying
answer um I think a lot of that does
depend on the industry sector though
right so um you know if you have a
situation where uh let's see like you
know warehouses or manufacturing things
where there are just these you know kind
of uh highly repetitive tasks that are
done over and over again that's the kind
of thing that is I think sort of ripe
for
automation through artificial
intelligence um I think in other cases
though even with things that we see like
you know you see all the time articles
that get pushed or you know published
out there reposted on LinkedIn or
whatever about like oh there's this AI
model that is able to give more accurate
uh diagnoses than most doctors or more
accurate legal advice than most lawyers
or whatever despite the fact that we see
stuff like that I still think
um those careers those areas are going
to be highly you know human intensive
right I mean there still is definitely a
lot of value in the human connection the
human human interaction uh of healthare
right you know kind of that bedside
manner if you will uh that you get with
a human nurse or a human doctor um so I
think there are certain things that just
because of the nature of what it is
we're never really going to see it
automated again it might be enhanced or
kind of augmented by through the use of
AI or ml but we're never going to see
humans just be straight up replaced in
in certain industry
sectors uh thank you so much Jeremy for
answering that I hope pre that answers
your question you can let us know if you
have any followup questions on the
YouTube live chat box as we move on uh
we have talked about the skills here we
have talked about the hottest career
paths we can take up uh in 2024 and uh
we have also talked about what's
changing in the data science space in
2024 so what exactly is stopping you
from becoming a data science expert so
you can see a quick poll on the screen
this is a multiple choice poll uh you
can select multiple options here because
there can be multiple concerns or
challenges right when it comes to
aspiring for a data science career so uh
this poll is to understand what exactly
is the challenge you're facing when it
comes to uh taking up a career in data
science or becoming a data science
expert uh you can just choose from these
four options here uh in case uh that
answers basically your uh challenge here
I just I'll just read out these options
for you the first one I can't find a
program with a fully comprehensive
curriculum second one I wouldn't get the
Practical exposure I need to become job
ready third one I find it difficult to
learn from prerecorded videos and the
last one my work should be won't allow
me enough time for learning uh if uh
these are the four challenges you face
you can let us know here uh but in case
if this does not cover your uh challenge
or concern when it comes to taking up a
career in data science or becoming a
data science expert you can let us know
on the chat or in the Q&A box as well so
please don't worry for folks who have
joined us live on YouTube you can let us
know on the chat box there as
well also uh folks uh we'll be taking
the uh questions from the Q&A box uh
towards the end of the session U there
is a special duration for the Q&A part
uh so please do put down your questions
in the Q&A box if you have any questions
about about the program or also data
science career in general we would love
to help you
out awesome I think most of the folks
have already responded for the poll here
so I think I'll just give 5 Seconds more
for the poll so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll and also share the results
with you folks let's see what is your
biggest concern here when it comes to
taking up a career in data science or
becoming a data science expert so as we
see that 72% of the folks have voted for
I wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become job ready and 36% of the
folks have voted for my work should
allow me enough time for Learning and
31% of the folks have voted for I can't
find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum and 15% of the
folks have voted for I find it difficult
to learn from prerecorded videos uh so
thank you so much for sharing that with
us now let us quickly give you an
introduction of the calex data science
bootcamp so calex data science boot camp
comes with a comprehensive curriculum
and Industrial line learning path uh you
get access to integrated labs and
handsone uh projects for practical
experience uh you you get access to
online virtual classrooms with peer and
instructor interaction uh and this
program duration is of 6 months uh so
you can just complete it by giving five
to 10 hours per week uh in case you are
a working professional uh so uh this
program basically makes it flexible to
fit your LIF schedule and also this is
in collaboration with our silver
business partner IBM we'll be talking
more about that uh in the next slide and
at the end of it all you get a CTIC ctma
boot camp certification which you can
see on the screen from California
Institute of Technology for the Caltech
data science boot camp and also you get
certificates for core and elective
courses as well we'll be talking more
about that in the upcoming slides and 25
plus handson projects to work on uh on
integrated Labs master classes from CTIC
ctma and also our silver business
partner IBM exclusive hackathons AMA
sessions by IBM and you receive up to 14
uh cus from calch C ctme which is
equalent to 140 hours of learning
learning so that's great and also you
get to be a part of the calch ctm circle
membership and uh you get to basically
part of an online convocation which is
pretty interesting where you cannot just
invite your closest family but also your
far relatives and your friends as well
to attend your online convocation by
CTIC
here now let's talk about the CTIC ctm
Advantage here so California Institute
of Technology is a 130 year old
institution uh it's a home and a matter
of many noble lence and it currently RS
in the uh ranks in the top five
universities worldwide and having a
calex ctma on your CB is prestigious
accomplishment recognized
worldwide here now talking about the IBM
Advantage here where you get access to
exclusive hackathons and ask mething
sessions by IBM master classes by IBM uh
industry recognized IBM certificates and
list of courses in collaboration with
IBM as well our programming for data
science python for data science these
are the courses certificates you'll be
getting for elect for certificates and
also I think someone asked about the
eligibility and the pr sites uh in the
Q&A box or in the chat here basically if
you're eligible for this program or not
so let me just quickly take you through
that so uh you need to have a prior
knowledge or experience in programming
and Mathematics you need to be at least
18 years uh and have a high school
diploma or equivalent and also you need
preferably uh two plus years of
experience of formal working screens is
preferred now uh I think someone asked
on the chat box here basically how good
one has to be in maths to be uh
successful in data science career joury
and also how much of mathematics are we
expecting them to know like programming
and
Mathematics yeah it's an excellent
question I would say
um the kind of two most essential things
in math
um that you need need to understand
actually it would be hard to only do two
let's maybe say three um so you should
be very familiar with Statistics uh
we'll say statistics and probability
we'll group them together um and being
able to kind of
understand uh things like selection bias
things like that that would actually
kind of confound a model so that you can
uh be able to interpret what your models
are doing make recommendations about how
to make models better understand why
your models might not be performing uh
as well as you'd like them to or need
them
to uh the other thing that you really
really need is linear algebra but not
like any deep linear algebra just uh
enough that you really understand
vectors matrices um the idea of like
what is a vector space uh how does
matrix multiplication work and certain
other Matrix operations like
transposition things like that um you
can actually get uh this if you're
interested in textbooks uh this one this
is just linear algebra and its
applications by David clay uh very
gentle introduction to linear algebra
doesn't really assume that you have a
whole bunch of you know deeper technical
background so excellent I think first
textbook in linear linear algebra if
you're kind of looking for a quick start
there and then a little bit of
differential calculus uh just to
understand the idea of derivatives what
they are how they're used in
optimization things like that because
the way that we actually
fit uh models to data does involve
calculus and um it actually involves
rather High dimensional multivariable
calculus but I think um if you just kind
of get sort of the uh the general idea
of what differentiation is and how it's
used in optimization that should be
enough because actually a lot of the
tools that are used today like tensor
flow or Pi torch uh actually kind of do
the auto
differentiation uh so you don't actually
need to like calculate these high
dimensional gradients you just kind of
need to understand like how is it that
we're using calculus to fit the model to
optimize the
model uh thank you so much JY for
answering that I think we have gotten
plenty of questions uh related to what
you've answered I hope that answers your
question please do let us know if you
have any followup questions as well I
think uh someone a has asked about the
name of the books I've replied jebra but
I'll put it in the in the chat uh let's
see I have to make sure I can chat with
everybody so it's
called oh whoops why am I not typing oh
I was typing on the wrong keyboard I
have two keyboards
here so linear algebra and it's
applications this is actually the Third
Edition
by David's C lay there you go so that's
in
the that's in the chat so that was uh
the textbook that was used for my first
class in linear algebra and from my from
my undergrad but so excellent textbook
very gentle introduction um so yeah
that's the one I would
recommend uh a thank you thank you so
much for J me for sharing that uh and uh
let's talk about how this program
prepares you so let's talk about how the
program builds your data science skills
step by step can you take us through the
steps
J yeah absolutely
so uh like many programs we start with a
sort of an orientation uh just to sort
of you know lay out the ground rules
right it's almost like syllabus week
right so this is what you expect from
you can expect from us this is what we
expect from you uh you know kind of just
gives you uh sort of quick like how to
succeed right at this uh in this program
then we get into the uh statistics so uh
you know Essentials about statistics for
data science so
um yeah and you know again we think a
lot
about experiment
design uh possible confounding factors
all that kind of stuff because in real
data sets that's like a real thing you
have to deal with right uh
so then we get into tools that you
you'll actually use so like our
programming for data science R is
actually the first language that I
learned for data
science uh I've used it on a number of
projects in Industry
so really really great for the data
exploration the statistical analysis um
visualizations reporting things like
that um so excellent tool for that kind
of stuff I think it also is really great
for a lot of the kind of more classical
statistical modeling has a lot of really
fantastic built-in tools for that um
then we get into python which um really
kind of is more of a general purpose
language so like R was kind of like made
with statistical analysis in mind um
which means it's very good and very
powerful for that kind of thing
but where it's not a general purpose
programming language it actually makes
it rather Limited in terms of like
actually deploying stuff or implementing
things you know at sort of like an
Enterprise scale um I think they're
they're doing a lot of work to sort of
catch it up but I think at this point
you know p just kind of has become sort
of the winner like the clear winner the
sort of like de facto you know language
for data science so uh I think at this
point the industry is pretty Set uh in
its ways in terms of that we're going to
just use Python now for most things so
you'll have to learn about python for
data science which includes sort of the
like data science uh sort of core stack
so that would be numpy
scipi uh map plot lib for visualizations
pandas which gives us access to data
frames to deal with more General T
tabular data um scikit learn which is an
excellent toolbox for a lot of uh kind
of classical machine learning algorithms
things like that um then we get into
applied data science with python and
this is where we actually start thinking
about things like um how do we kind of
prepare data for machine learning
algorithms how do we get insights out of
data um you know what are techniques
around dealing with say like missing
values outliers
um you know what are the different kinds
of statistical assumptions that are made
by different methodologies for dealing
with these things maybe when should you
actually not do anything about missing
values maybe the missingness is actually
important uh you know in and of itself
so there are all kinds of things there
that um kind of get addressed uh you
know to kind of prepare you for the
deeper subject which comes next which is
that we actually just get into uh
machine learning so you'll learn about a
number of different algor gorithms there
so you know Classics that are still used
all the time like uh linear regression
logistic regression but then also you'll
get into things like K nearest neighbors
decision trees random Forest um I
believe we get into like perceptrons and
support Vector machines as well so uh
yeah a good kind of like broad
introduction to a number of different
machine learning algorithms than what
they're used for you know how to apply
them things like that um then data
visualization with tableau is actually a
very
popular and very powerful I think uh
tool for kind of sharing what you've
learned from your
data so you'll kind of uh very often
you'll sort of implement your sort of
reporting to decision makers within a
company by publishing reports and
dashboards to Tableau and so then
instead of say looking at like a a slide
deck or like reading a paper or
something like that that you've written
they'll like you know log into this uh
Tableau dashboard and start looking
through looking through that and they
can actually do some analyses themselves
it's actually flexible enough to sort of
allow some of that but for the most part
you know if you have like a department
head or somebody like that who is trying
to look at you know something that
you've put together in Tableau they are
mostly just consuming you know the the
things that you've built uh and then
finally um you know so I know that many
of you mentioned uh that of the things
that's kind of stopped you from being a
data scientist is sort of the lack of
like real Hands-On you know uh you kind
of like job relevant experience so
that's a thing that um simply learning
Caltech also recognizes a weakness of
many programs and so they look to uh
address that head-on by having this sort
of Industry focused Capstone project
where you'll have I can't remember
exactly how long it's something like a
couple of weeks um but you'll actually
have time to kind of complete a project
starting from like getting into the data
analyzing the data cleaning it up
getting it ready for
modeling uh implementing the model and
then ultimately publishing the results
to uh a Tablo dashboard very much like
you would do in like a real uh you know
real industry setting right so uh that
very much gives you like a real sense
for in many data science jobs like what
would you do day-to-day in that job so
that you can you know kind of understand
what it's really like and you can
demonstrate that you have that knowledge
and that capability uh to you know any
hiring managers that you're looking to
uh to get a job
with thank you so much jery for taking
us through the prog uh steps here how
basically the program builds their step
data science skills step by step and
also about the electives here uh so the
electives here are business analytics
with Excel uh data science Essentials
for generative AI prompt engineering and
Char GPD data storytelling using powerbi
and calch data science master classes so
electives here are optional they come as
a part of the program and you don't have
to pay anything extra for that it is up
to you if you want to take them up also
uh let's not talking about the tools
libraries and platforms you will need to
learn in this program I think python is
something J has already mentioned pandas
Tabu T flow numai mat Li FBI which we
already mention MySQL sci-fi my mapping
uh and SCI kit skills and our
programming are the tools platforms
libraries you'll be learning in this
program also uh the Capstone projects
here so I talking about the Capstone
projects Jeremy has already mentioned
how basically it is so important to have
a capston project or the industry based
projects which you get to learn from
this a particular program which you can
add in your portfolio once you're done
with the program and showcase uh to it
to your future employers uh this
basically shows a true experience uh
where you basically these caption
project mimic real life business
scenarios this definitely help folks who
basically come from a completely
different background and have no
experience in data
science also uh uh we have global
leaders as program advisers Rick Hefner
who's the calch ctma program director
with over 40 years of experience in
systems development and has served in
academic industry and research positions
uh so uh basically these global leaders
make sure that simply learn is
delivering as per standards of CTIC here
and let's talk about the learner
outcomes here so uh the interesting part
is the previous classes have consisted
of Learners from World Class
organizations and diverse Industries uh
they come from Industries like it
software product Banking bfsi and others
and also uh companies like Amazon
Microsoft barlay Google enture IBM
Oracle Bosch Vago and many more like
that and also simply them provides
career assess Services as well which
helps you with your job s uh where you
get access to job portal Talent Inc
resume rabbit and resume re review and
rewrite service from Top resume and also
one-on-one interview Service as well
from Top resume so uh I think we have
gotten few questions here on the Q&A box
Journey uh I have actually as we have
gotten plenty of questions what I've
done is I've just sent you few questions
on the chart here uh because it'll be so
hard to find so let's see that first
question which we have from Lori Freeman
ask that which role Works closest with
the business on using data to make uh
decisions so the role that actually
works I think the very closest with the
business would be either the business
analyst or the uh the data scientist so
um the business analyst uh really kind
of mainly works with the business
stakeholders to gather sort of the
requirements right so they really kind
of you know nail down exactly what are
the requirements exactly what the
criteria around what we're doing um and
then um the data scientist then works
very closely with them to again get a
great sense for you know the environment
we're working in all the kind of nuances
around it how does this ultimately get
turned into a mathematical problem with
inputs and outputs and then how are we
measuring it how are we consuming the
output that kind of stuff so those two
roles I would say the most closely
aligned with with the
business uh thank you so much JY France
ing that I hope that answers your
question Lori uh you can let us know on
the chat or in the Q&A box if you have
any followup questions we have one more
question from uh Francis here uh ask is
asking that upon enrolling in the
self-fed learning of data science
program through simply learn uh which is
put in place to help uh someone stuck
while learning I think um he's trying to
ask basically when they stuck while
learning in this part when they have
taken up this program what exactly we do
to help them
out yeah so
um if you are struggling or stuck on
anything we actually have a number of
resources uh we have the community board
which I think is sort of your first line
of defense where you can post a question
um there actually are faculty who look
at that so you know like if I have
students in my classes and I see them
posting uh which I do check that
regularly uh then you can actually you
know get answers that way if uh your
question is maybe a little more
complicated or a little more nuanced or
the thing that you're stuck on is a
little harder to describe and than you
know just what you could put in a
community post uh you actually can reach
out and set up kind of like a one-on-one
session so we do have like office hours
um so you can actually have kind of more
of a a
one-on-one kind of you know session with
an instructor to have them kind of help
you you know work through
that and then also I've even had this I
don't know if this is officially offered
uh through the program but this is
something that I've done where you know
you have students like we've said that
are in you know companies all over uh
and you know they'll want to talk about
you know hey we're trying to implement
this thing how do we get this off the
ground actually right like how do I work
with my data scientists to actually you
know enable them to get this done uh and
I'll actually just set up a time you
know well sometimes kind of do that
communication outside of the community
board or whatever they'll they'll hit me
up on LinkedIn or whatever and I'll just
kind of like take like a a half hour or
60 Minute call maybe uh to kind of talk
them through that kind of thing if
they're if they're stuck in you know
something that's maybe not directly
related to the class but that is data
science related um yeah that's that's uh
something that I I do quite often
actually
so uh thank you so much for answering
that Francis I hope that answers your
question uh and do let us know if you
have any followup question for us as
well I think we'll take one more
question before we move on uh this is
the last one which I've sent you uh
can't make out the name from the email
ID uh let let us know what is your name
as I read out your question as well so
with no background in Tech uh do you
think a student who completes a boot
camp would be equipped enough to obtain
a data analyst versus data scientist
position job or would a master degree
provide better skill
equipment so so um if you don't have any
background in Tech I think that may be a
bit of a hurdle that you would need to
get over to just get that first position
right but once you've gotten that first
one right the first one will be the
hardest one to get and then once you've
gotten that first one at that point now
you you have industry experience you
just have to you know kind of
demonstrate your ability to do the job
in that one role uh you know and then
then you should be fine after that uh I
think as long as
[Music]
you
do have have scientist you should be
a
if you're looking to be a we have
answered a few of your career
transitions questions as well and also
questions about programming mathematics
the knowledge of it the basics of it
which you need to know before joining
the program is how much is required how
much is not I will take more questions
but before that we would love to know
are you interested in enrolling into the
calics data science boot camp we can see
a quick poll in screen also just to
remind you for attending this webinar we
actually are giving a bonus offer for
folks who basically select the yes uh in
this enrollment poll you can see a quick
poll which is launched on your screen uh
where it says would you like to enroll
in the program of calex data science
boot camp and uh by selecting yes here
in this poll you basically can Avail the
bonus offer as well for uh starting a
cohort uh which I'll be sharing what are
the upcoming cohorts and also the
enrollment steps of the program and the
program fee as well uh in the upcoming
slides uh we are a little uh beyond the
time of timing of the session few
minutes so we'll try to take a little
faster but meanwhile if you have any
more questions you can let us know on
the chat here or you can always write us
to write to us at ask us at.net I'll
just share that email ID uh in sometime
uh in case we are not able to answer
your queries and also folks who have
joined us live on YouTube you can let us
know also if you have any
questions I think I'll just give 10
seconds more for the poll here because
as I was speaking I I'm seeing a lot of
interest coming towards enrollment so
that's great so I think I'll just keep
the PO live for 10 seconds more and and
meanwhile I see uh a lot of more
questions coming up in the Q&A box we'll
try to take as many questions as
possible if the time allows uh and uh
meanwhile we'll just take you through
the enrollment steps of the program and
also ask you basically when do you plan
to join also uh in case you're confused
like when exactly uh you are planning to
join you're not you have not decided
that yet that's totally okay we will be
asking you that particular question in
the upcoming slide just to get a little
bit of an idea where when do you plan to
join because we have a lot of cohorts
that basically get scheduled throughout
the year so uh if you have not planned
when to join that's totally okay you can
Avail the bonus offer even throughout
the year so that's not a problem at all
so uh I think most of the folks have
already shared responses for the poll
here so I think I'll just give last five
seconds for the poll here so as we have
talked about the skills we have talked
about the CER paths you can take up in
data science in 2024 and how you can un
leash your career as well and through
the program uh projects you can work on
the caption projects the industry based
projects you get to work on uh the IBM
being the silver business partner in
partner in this program uh where you get
cor elective certificates as well a calc
ctma certificate as well from California
Institute of Technology and uh we uh
covered a lot of tools libraries and
platforms which we talked about as well
so last five seconds for the poll here
which you can see on your screen uh
would you like to enroll in the calex
data science boot
camp awesome I think uh I'll just give
last 5 seconds so 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll and thank you so
much for sharing your interest towards
enrollment into calics data science root
camp we saw a lot of interest a lot of
yeses so for the folks who have shared
basically interest towards enrollment
let me quickly take you through the
enrollment steps here so you need to
follow three simple easy steps
uh basically U once learning consultant
from simply don't be reaching out to you
they will be basically taking you
through the similar enrollment steps so
I'm just giving you a glimpse of that uh
so you need to submit an application to
us at ask us simple.net uh based on that
your application will be going for
review the calch ctm reviews your uh
qualifications based on the eligibility
and the preite which is shared earlier
and uh based on that you'll be getting
an admissions offer uh from uh learning
Consultants from SAR who basically will
be contacting you with that and also the
up upcoming cohart and the program fee
for CTIC data science boot camp the
classes will be starting on January 22nd
2024 that's next year and also the
induction for uh this particular cohort
will be on the same day January 22nd
2024 and we do have many more cohorts
which basically come throughout the year
so uh you don't have to worry about it
that in case you're not planning to join
immediately we do have other options as
well throughout the year so the program
fee for this one is 8,000 USD
and I think someone asked about if there
are any Emi options available so we do
have that you can basically Avail for as
low as $74 per month uh for more
assistance you can always reach out to
us at ask us at s.net I'll share that
email ID on the chat here uh in some
time also um in this particular cohart
we only take uh folks uh basically 25 to
30 folks only in order to make sure
you're getting all the attention that is
required while you're taking of this
program and also for the upcoming courts
as well we have kept it limited to 25 to
30 only uh now as you have shared your
interest towards enrollment we would
love to know how soon do you plan to
enroll uh in the DAT in the calex data
science boot camp so you can basically
see four quick options here the first
one is immediately second one within
three months third one within six months
and the last one more than six month
from now so uh as I mentioned earlier
folks who are planning to join
immediately can select the first option
and folks who are still thinking about
it are not sure when exactly they want
to join you can select any of these
three options which is the most suitable
for you to Avail the bonus offer so I
was speaking as I was speaking I see
folks have already started sharing the
responses for the polio so that's
great I'll just give five seconds more
for the poll here before we move on also
uh I'll I'll just quickly share the
email ID as well uh in case you have any
questions if you need any assistance you
can basically uh reach out to us at ask
us at simply
h.net so once the webinar ends in case
you have any questions I've share the
email ID here you can basically reach
out to us at ask us at.net and I think
I'll just give 5 Seconds more for the
poll here because I can see most of the
folks have already responded for the
poll so last 5 Seconds 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll thank you so much
for sharing that with us now one last
poll to understand if you need
assistance into enrolling into the
[Music]
program okay you can see a quick poll
which is launched on the screen with yes
or no if you need assistance in
enrolling to the program you can select
one of the options uh this is for folks
who have already shared interest towards
enrollment and also uh they have let us
know when do you plan to enroll this is
a very important poll question uh so we
have exceeded few minutes of the program
uh we just
uh let me quickly take a look through
the YouTube live chat here in case will
uh we have any questions
here oh I think we have answered pramsh
and PR pel's and banga perel's
question
already so we have actually answered all
of those questions by during the session
itself so yeah I was just going through
the questions here I think I'll just end
this poll because I see most of the
folks have already shared the responses
so last 5 Second folks 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end the poll thank you so much
uh folks for joining the session we are
a little Beyond our time of the session
uh thank you so
much while we will basically taking them
through the steps uh we do have a lot
more questions to get answered but I
think we'll just uh take those questions
in the email ID here which I've shared
here and we'll answer those questions
for you about anything about the program
in general or any other program you to
take up with simply learn uh and jery
thank you so much for taking the time
out for this program review of calex
data science boot camp uh would you like
to see anything to the crowd here before
we end the session
uh yeah just thank you so much for uh
for being here for sticking with us it
was a pleasure uh being here and talking
to all of you and I hope that this was
very very helpful and that uh for those
of you who are really seriously looking
into starting a career in data science I
I hope you do it and I wish you all the
best uh we definitely need uh we need
all of the uh all the data scientists we
can
get agree agree to that and I think we
have answered few more questions on the
chat and in the Q Q box as well I think
Jeremy has done that as well so uh thank
you so much folks you have been a great
audience and we would love to see you in
the upcoming cohorts as for the interest
you have shown here as well in the
enrollment Bood here so we would love to
see you there in the upcoming cohorts of
calex data science board cam so thank
you so much folks have a have a good day
uh good evening where are you joining us
from thank you so much folks we'll be
ending the session now now also about
the post webinar survey poll which I
told you about in the starting in case
you have missed it and you won the
webinar certificate and the proof of
attendance so you can basically uh put
down your full name in the post of surve
we will just pop up when we end the
session so just wait for it and go and
put fill down the survey which you will
see from uh Zoom uh once we end the
session so thank you once again thank
you